welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm really excited
to be joined by
bernadette clarke who is the director of
the public sector division at evolution
recruitment
bernadette has worked in the industry
for over a decade and within this time
she has consistently progressed
to either a director level or a
leadership position
across the number of brands that she's
worked for throughout her career
bernadette is extremely passionate about
moving the needle on diversity within
the sector that she
recruits in as well as the recruitment
industry
she actively mentors within women in
recruitment
and also has recently joined us at the
recruitment mentors community as well
now as well as this she has launched the
exchange nhs podcast where
she actively interviews leaders within
the public sector
and in 2017 launched her plus day to
manchester
uh which is a community and working to
connect
inspire support and empower the north
west
uk's women in data bernadette or should
i say bernie and i said
bernadette a number of times there
yeah well welcome to the podcast how are
you you make me sound amazing
[Laughter]
when you hear it like that it sounds
great doesn't it yeah plenty of great
things to
talk about so where we always like to
start on this podcast is
so in your opinion the million dollar
question million pound question like
what what cataracts
and traits do you think make up a highly
successful
recruitment consultant in your eyes
so probably ask the question a few times
over the years and then
and and obviously done my fair share of
of hiring um
you know people from such that have
maybe graduated or
um want to work in that sort of
recruitment and sales environment
and i suppose there's there's always
sort of common themes running through
the ones that
uh make it the people that become
successful and then
you sort of look around yourself sort of
ten years and they're managing
teams of their own or businesses of
their own or people have gone on to
either open their own businesses and um
so i think the number one thing
is is ambition and it's sort of why how
you you quantify that it's sort of
ambitious in terms of money
money's one thing money's you know
that's the financial side i think you
need more than that you need
an internal drive um and i don't
you can't say where that comes from in a
person whether it's your background
whether it's your aspirations whether
it's your culture whether it's your
you know the people around you but
the people that have been successful
want a little bit more out of life than
than your average
and so they're willing the effort in and
i think
work ethic for me if someone's not
to put the graft in in recruitment it's
probably there's a million and one other
jobs out there that you can do
and so having a strong work ethic
is very very important for me
um so let's let the other
obviously we can like you said i know
the the drive piece there which i think
is really interesting because i think
yeah everyone has their own story and
they've been on their own journey but
let's talk about yours then like where
do you think that comes from for you
in your story like where's that do you
think it's coming from the environment
you grew up in or
where do things come from yeah
definitely i think you know we're all
we're all a product of our
of our early years aren't we um and
i think you know sort of quite humble
beginnings for me um
one side of my family is quite uh well
off and the other very much
sort of uh working class and so i
probably had a little bit of uh
saw a sort of a side of life that you
could have a
a window into but definitely my my
immediate family
very very working class um and
grew up in a place called the isle of
deputy which is not not
known to many people but um you know
quite
as sort of humble humble beginnings we
didn't have
a lot of spare cash or anything like
that so you're there for
um seeing what other people have and the
holiday
in the house and the lifestyle and
you know i knew that i had to um educate
myself in the first instance you know i
think
um i was always thought by those around
me that
education would be our path out of when
i say how because me and my sister
are part of of the the situation that we
were in really so
going to university getting a good
degree and then
being able to make choices as to your
career
that was the basis and the foundation of
what everything else was put on
yeah i love that so just for context and
for people listening
um obviously so right now
like you do you manage are you just
involved on the contract side
yeah i've been a contract uh biller a
contract consultant for
really for 17 years and whilst i manage
those billers um and
you know and direct that team i still
have my toe in the
dip my toe in the water and i still use
lots of clients now
but contract's always been me through
and throughout yeah that's holding to
make sure for
people listening and then and then have
you always been in so i can see you
in the first company you work for it
says social care but so have you always
been around the public sector have you
also
have you also been involved in the
private sector as well has always been
in the public sector of interest so
morgan hunt
is a pub recruitment company i worked
there for nine years
um opened up sort of various different
offices for them regionally
um but the the teams that i ran were
always able to actually housing
um and and social care as we've just
mentioned
um but i also ran i opened the
manchester leeds birmingham
newcastle offices um and
the um and then i moved to rouleon um
which was entirely
private sector so around six years so
and moved to technology at that point
um to doing tech digital i.t data
um you know devon testing as well with
the markets that i ran
um and and that was purely private
sector customers when i moved to
evolution
i was um brought on as the director for
the private sector
tech contract team um for the uk
did that for two years and then it's
really only
as a result of code that i directed our
efforts
to deliver digital into the nes okay
got it perfect overview so that that's
really good content so i guess
look let's let's just dive into like the
really good stuff then that
i think people are going to want to
obviously hear from your
point of view like what what do you
believe
sort of makes a great contract recruiter
great
like what what do you think great
contract builders have in common
would you say when i ask that you what
immediate comes up for you
i think um contract is
probably gonna i don't want to upset
anyone that's a parallel here but
um contract is complex you know there's
a little bit more to it than placing you
know even in terms of the compliance
that's attached to it and all of that
kind of thing so
lots and lots of moving parts so you
have to be really good
at keeping your eye on the ball at
business development as well as doing
your
you know managing your contractors um
you only grow
obviously if you're in your book if
you're good at managing your base
and not letting that base you know those
runners sort of fall away from you so
you have to have your eye on anything
new new jobs business development
contractor management and
bringing your your pool of contractors
through so you have to be
good at all of those things at one
single time which
people find that quite difficult to
manage all of those things
um i think contract tends to be a little
bit more sales
there are people that you know that are
waiting for the next um
contract uh deliverer ticket to come
through are they you know you need to be
able to have very very good hunting
skills
um and and you know that's sort of not
taking no for an answer the resilience
and determination that everyone
uh in recruitment needs to display um
but i think you know i'm looking around
the room that that we
you know the office that i'm in now and
a couple of them worked at the weekends
more than happy to put in a little bit
of craft in the evenings
and i don't know if people want to hear
or not but you know it's it's about
going the extra mile and being probably
prepared to make a few sacrifices in
your personal life throughout the week
in order to get those gains eventually
so that you can
you know you enjoy other aspects of your
life
sure so a couple of things i just want
to sort of
zoom in on that most people most
recruiters will message me that they
want
to find out learn about ask people on
this podcast so
the two things are one the the new
business side of things that's always a
popular area that people always message
you around want to
hear how people have improved on that
and these types of things and then two
the um the the time management the
systems like what you've
what i guess what your day plan looks
like now or when at the peak of when you
as a contract builder compared to what
it looked like early on
people know obviously hear these such
things so let's start with um
the um the time management and these
sorts of things if that's okay with you
so you said
even more and i feel like obviously i
used to work in
um permanent recruitment and people
listening who
operate in that world as well will also
say to you that they're juggling
loads of spinning loads of plates and
these types of things right but i think
fair to say as a whenever i've
interviewed contractors they've got to
be like
really on the ball with like everything
that's going on like that person that's
come
into the end of their i don't know
there's yeah there might be
even even more going on so i guess
that's a really common thing that people
want to know so like
sort of bernie early on in her career as
you were working out what worked for you
and these type of things like what
what what has massively changed in your
sort of day plan when you were
really producing the the higher numbers
compared to when you were early on out
of interest like what does a typical day
look like
what did it look like when you was in a
fill out billing rather
i know i will go back a few years rather
than talk about the present time yeah
yeah yeah
um i think when you're first putting out
your
um you're not aware of like your ratios
you're not aware of how many games it
takes
for example to to put a job so i worked
that out quite quickly and for me
i needed to make about 25 bd calls to
then pull
uh a position and then um yeah you know
then you can work out how many
placements that you're going to make a
month and you can become quite
scientific about it um you're also
grafted to where you get into a customer
in the first place
and um i think people sort of miss a
trick a little bit you know they might
be doing lots and lots of
new business calls to new organizations
but have they fully maxed out
the organizations that they've already
placed with so you know the common thing
about sort of landing and expanding
that was probably where i did pretty
well
um i would always highlight where there
were pockets
of um of business that i could do and
then get people to recommend me over to
to other managers so you're actually
from one customer you might have
you know multiple contractors running if
i think about one particular customer i
worked with
um had about 30 contractors in one
organization
um so you could
whilst you've got risk there because
what if suddenly that tap test yes
less diversified yeah yeah and and
you've got sort of lots of eggs in one
basket
um obviously that really helped me
significantly in terms of time
so i would i think when i was probably
doing the best in terms of
my financials i had about four or five
customers where i had multiple contracts
and then i had ones and twos
in say another five or six customers
um yeah and that sort of spread with the
book and i always try
to sort of um enhance what i already had
because getting into a
new organization was was a lot harder
yeah and terms of day plan
um in in
in morgan it was um really
pre-pre-designed for you not an awful
lot of autonomy
like okay you could have walked into any
morgan hunter at ten o'clock
and everyone was switching to bd from
candidates right okay like little robots
almost
and and i suppose after a couple of
years you get a bit fed up with that
because you want your own to add your
own spin on things
yeah yeah but there's definitely
something to be said for structure
and something to be said for you know
that discipline and routine
um because i still instill that now into
to people that join
fair enough once people have got sort of
a little bit more experience they can
they can you know sort of change times
that they're doing things
but broadly speaking you have to do some
biz every single day as a contract
recruiter
if you don't if you spend all your time
on delivery you're going to turn around
and not know what jobs you're going to
be placing next
so even when my consultants are at their
busiest
i still ask them to carve out of
business development bay
and i think that's it's a bit of a
golden a golden rule
a you know i've seen so many people sort
of spend a week or two week delivery
dollar and then not have anything to
sort of turn around
and and be able to still be playing so
you limit yourself and restrict yourself
significantly um i think also we were
talking about contractor management
and you've got to weave that into every
single day as well
don't and you could go a week without
speaking to your contractors well
they'll soon be being poached by someone
else if you don't
keep that relationship so um it's about
being hot on on all of those
all of those specs and what and what
so just quickly just getting really
practical here because this is what
people love so
yeah you've explained that really well
and then i guess just what what i guess
what systems what things really work for
you to
have the best possible chance of keeping
on top of all those things was it you
you
pretty much blocked out your diary for
every activity
did you have a to-do list that worked
for you like what sort of i don't know
there'll be some days that are better
than others but like
besides when the whole team around
you're doing the same thing that
obviously helps but like for you
what really works for you in the end or
typically
yeah i think being um organization has
always come
quite easily to me um it's not
i've got a hundred to do lists in my
personal as well as my
my work and i always write a to-do list
the night before
um okay it's clear and um
if anything hasn't been actioned it
rolls to the next day without being
you know my inbox is always super super
clean um it's either filed actioned or
it's yet to do
and i would beat if i had more than 10
emails in my inbox yeah they they you
know i run things very very leanly and
that helps me sort of see the wood
tree when things are busy because it's
so easy to become overwhelmed
um different organizations that i've
worked in have had different systems so
morgan hunt was bond adapt i absolutely
loved it it had a
you know it had a great way of sort of
doing your callbacks
uh monitoring what your outputs were
each day and then i pressed the button
and i could see what my team's outputs
were
um i love dashboards and being able to
see
you know your stats and what is actually
what you've actually achieved and then
link that into the monthly um
you know but called out you know having
reminders and you know
making sure you've start from maybe a
pay-per-day plan when you're first
starting don't you but
soon you you become customed and do
certain things on on automatic
um uh rouleon was a bespoke database
which
in my opinion wasn't that great it
didn't help me an awful lot
and it's more of a candidate management
tool than this development tool
um and at evolution we use multiple
things but
um we're we're big fans of trello
yeah and um you know i think working in
tech
um people have very you know there's
much more advanced tools than trello out
there but for me it's a really
useful tool moving cards along everyone
having shared access to those boards so
that you can see where
updates are getting the notices through
so you can understand
where things have moved from um and then
just being able to go into it log into a
trello board from wherever you are and
being able to manage your your own time
see what's going on
yeah yeah nice and you can you use a lot
of trello for free by the way for anyone
listening that's sort of
always trying to look for a tool that
can help them and i guess just really
quickly
so you organize your inbox by filed
action than to do you said yeah
absolutely okay nice
i hardly say right now as i've been on
things all day my inbox will be doing um
but i have a rule that so i can't i
can't leave
until it's either action door put it on
the to-do list for the next day
or you know to be quite rigid and
disciplined with yourself because you
could easily
let that that slip but if that slipped
for me then i would know that
i'm not completely i'm not
no awesome thank you for sharing that so
i guess the the next thing then let's
sort of keep i guess it'd be great if
you could
keep this maybe in like the last sort of
12 to 18 months and maybe you could
speak from
yourself or even your team just because
i feel like
the landscape has changed so much and
and that's what sort of people want to
hear so i guess
the next thing then on like what has
been sort of the most reliable way then
for you and your team to win business
um and get the most out of that business
development time there's one thing
making the time for it but then there's
another thing doing it effectively
so like what what comes up for you and
there might be a couple of ways but
what's ended up being like
the the best sort of most reliable way
of
you and your team to be winning business
and on the contract side of things out
of interest so
evolution didn't recruit the nhs
18 months ago and how we are
i would say especially without blown
around trump it's recognized as a brand
that delivers into the nhs um
definitely multiple customers across
multiple nhs organizations and
winning business ahead of competition
um quite quite easily um
and i think the thing that and and you
know hisham you've
definitely had something to do with this
as well in
to understand how personal brand could
really aid me
and i very much enjoyed doing the
sessions that you ran at evolution um
sort of getting your name out there but
by giving something back to the market
that you're
in helps you then to take something from
that market
and yes um and by taking i mean being
able to place business
and make revenue um but
the the single biggest uh i suppose
tool in our toolbox is the the past the
round tables and the article series that
we do
um i was able to leverage the experience
i had from her plus data
um in hosting sort of quite large
and understanding the types of
conversations that people wanted to talk
about
um and then take that into
i've done a female leadership series um
in tech in the hs
had the privilege of interviewing around
um city female leaders in tech
who've become my customers and because
you're building up sort of quite a bond
with them
or as you're talking um then it sort of
makes sense that then you'll
end up working with them and delivering
their their talents as well
um yeah i definitely didn't want to be
pigeonholed into just
talking to women um so for me
um i was looking for angles to talk
about
uh things that appealed to to men and
women
um and men definitely want to talk more
about the tech and the projects that
they've
um they've you know delivered the things
that they've actually
um executed and facilitated in the
organization
um they want to talk about achievement
much more than challenges
women quite comfortable to talk about
the diversity angle
so i've kind of just appealed to both
and then i've
i regularly now um organized roundtables
i held a webinar yesterday
um on a robotic process something that i
wouldn't thought
i'd be doing 18 months ago but you find
yourself
in those sort of positions and then you
become very very comfortable and
familiar at doing the hosting side
as you're doing today yeah yeah for sure
i mean that's been our best angle
so so just on this then you don't have
to give us all the secrets and like go
into
loads of details and processes right but
like would you mind just like painting a
picture for us
like obviously i i understand this
because it's also a great tool for me
and how i've grown
my so like like just talk to us in like
recruitment like terms like if i'm
listening to this i'm going okay bernie
but like how
like how does it how do you go from
speaking to people about
webinars podcasts articles to them these
people
giving you vacancies and opportunities
to work with them like what what is the
typical
journey out of interest and maybe just
painting a picture on there out of
interest do you
is it that you always follow up and is
it always that you're you do bring it up
at some point i don't know like what
how does it typically happen i've been
trans i know it i know it will differ
because that's how it's happened for me
but
yeah i think um i understand your
questions and i think
some people could do lots of these nice
sort of questions interviews and
talk to people on round tables and
things like that but never uh
monetize it never yeah turn that into
anything commercial
and you know sit there and have lots and
lots of conversation but
no outcome so
very quickly explain who i am and and
what i actually
what i'm about what i want to do and why
i'm doing it so
for us we're a framework supplier on
several of the nhs frameworks so i make
a point of
stating it and some people will
be aware that you're you're going to um
talk to them about recruitment
you can tell maybe that's not the right
time to to broach it
um so it's all about reading people
isn't it and understanding what my time
is
but at no point do we ever shy away from
the fact that we're a recruiter
and i'm very proud to say that i deliver
lots of wonderful tech talent into the
nhs
um but then we talk about the things
that matter to people
i draw the connection that way that what
what matters to people
their careers their career choices the
improvements they work in
we talk about mental health diversity
i've gone to topics like black lives
matter because
people are people so i could be
i could be um i talk about people
disability
lgbtq because the nhs
hires all of those people of course it's
irrelevant
because we need to we should all be
taking our you know
playing our part in making our working
environments
more inclusive because our people will
then be more productive
and uh they will the organizations that
we're working with will be
uh more productive and more efficient so
you draw those connections and i will
sometimes you know it feels like a
little bit of a loose connection because
um what you're wanting to do is is place
their people
but as i mentioned i would never ever
ever shy away from
being a rooter it's one thing i say as a
recruiter
or i'll give them the context when we
frame the conversation
i'll tell them want to do it in the more
i want to podcast or i want to do
um a roundtable and the reason why but
then i say
let me give you the context and explain
that as a recruiter this is what we do
when i sit down
yeah i think that's the key point like
it's and that's the thing
like as a recruiter you need it's just
about getting more opportunities to
share
like who you are why you do well more
more and less about you but more about
them as like how you can help them so
it's like this is how we've been helping
people like you
these are the challenges that we help
them solve with the talent that we
provide them etc so like just
making sure i guess then at the relevant
part of the process
and talking about these things you're
going hey this is what we do we're proud
of it we're bloody good at it
just so you know and like what we're
yeah okay
but whatever if you missed the
opportunity to get
there you're kind of always going to
have a nice relationship much else
yeah exactly yeah okay cool but that's a
key part yeah yeah
so then just and then again just on this
before we're going to the next thing i
want to ask you about which is um
like just again getting a bit practical
here like what does the outreach look
like
because i think that's what people
interested as well because it's like the
typical reasons why
i may call a particular target client
will be
speccing in a cv i've got i know i've
helped such and such like you
or referral or whatever to like what
does that outreach look like out of
interest and how have you
found that being received has it been
received better have you got
more people coming back to you like what
does that outreach look like as well
to target prospect clients
so the same with any sort of um getting
together a project on linkedin of a
target audience
or um getting um
a the same situation would apply to this
um and you've got to be mindful that you
know i get 100 hit rate
um i get 100 hit rate when it's a
referral when someone says i've really
enjoyed talking to you about female
leadership please talk to my colleague
here
i'll copy you in and we will do the same
thing and i'll chat to her tonight about
how it was
that that's a hundred percent but if i'm
sort of um
sending out a mass message to people
yeah and
i would say i'd be i'd be happy if it
was around
40 um uh hit rate and i would think that
that would still be quite high
it's all about the way you the what you
put in the message
the um the uh
using leverage from your output so
getting your first one is probably going
to be the
most difficult um and so i
i chose someone in the marketplace that
was very prominent um
that i thought other people would be
very very keen to hear about
and if i got her to do it i had a
dominance
exactly and and so it gained it momentum
and it gained that momentum really
really quickly
i i appreciate every market there might
not be that
um that that one person but you know
your market it's you know a recruiter
knows their market pretty well
you can you can go to the like the
number one client in your market
and reach out to someone there um and
then
but the messaging has to be you know
really well written
it has to be the language that you're
using is non-recruitment
um your reasons have to be
you're not mentioning recruitment in any
of that message at all
yeah yeah i got him in um and and i'll
be
honest and say there's not a lot of ego
fluttering and telling people that they
they look amazing and they're exactly
the type of person that you want to have
speak to yeah yeah yeah and
clearly that works yeah i love that
okay and then just so before we finish
what i just really want to talk to you
about
is sort of um just around really you
always ended up in some sort of
leadership position and a few other
things but
just really quickly on this like what
how do you think like you you've started
to highlight this but you've been doing
recruitment as you said like 17 years
right so i i guess so yeah i just want
to like commend
i guess what i want to commend and
highlight here and maybe you can comment
like how like a lot of people would have
gone now i don't know how to do it or
like
i've we've always done it this way do
you know what i mean so i guess i don't
know i'm just
like curious as to like why was you able
to be open-minded to doing it this way
because i'm sure if i was to say to you
three years ago that you'd be doing
podcasts like i know you had the event
series but doing podcast webinars all
this and that would have been one of the
most effective ways for you to grow
your contract business you would have
gone good one or not sure about that
maybe so i don't know just curious about
that like how
what do you think why have you been able
to be so open-minded and fluid and
yeah and and i'd say so yes i have been
but also if i think about my boss
matthew
yeah you probably won't mind me saying
but he's over 55.
and so he would you think
you know he he won't be saying this at
all but you know he would you would
think
oh that he wouldn't be that you know
that on it that on
things that were yeah yeah horrendous
and trendy and
so it is that open-mindedness isn't it i
think it's just
you know we're never never as recruiters
we never know it all do we there's
always someone that's built more than
you that's
um knows more than you and yeah you know
i probably have walked in a little bed
and
t-shirt and all of those things but um
you have to move with the time
if you do not with the times then you're
going to be dead in the water
and i think i'd listen to you know to an
apple and
you know a good um there's a lot of
innovation at
um a lot of people that are you know it
is one of our core values
we you know collaborative and ambitious
and innovative and
you've got to then breathe haven't you
you can have something written on a wall
but you've actually got to be innovative
and i don't say i came up with it i
didn't come up with it by it by any
means
um in fact i would say go so far as to
say
i would have shied away from it i'm not
a outgoing
i've probably even said this to you and
we did the personal brand session yeah i
don't like i was quite i'm quite
actually naturally shy um don't
really like to be put out there
definitely when i'm doing
hosting a webinar yesterday with 80
people on it i
am racked with nerves a minute before um
and and yet i just also something about
um we're in a situation now where teams
and deo conferencing is just so
commonplace
you do something again again and again
it just wouldn't matter now whether it's
me and you talking or whether there's a
thousand people
there sat behind the screen i don't know
so i just
i'm confident now to talk in sort of
these environments really really freely
um i wouldn't say i would probably have
the same confidence face
um but i think a lot of it comes down to
characteristics are you prepared to sort
of take on other people's new ideas
um i'd credit definitely credit a chap
called chris bennett who i know you know
with pushing and you know pushing and
saying you know we
but i might have come up with some of
the ideas around doing the
um roundtable but definitely there's a
collaboration of people internally
we've got an innovative marketing team i
work with people that are
constantly pushing me and i quite like
it
i like being yeah that's amazing yeah so
before we finish then
um i just definitely want to make sure
that we talk about this
so women in recruitment right so
i guess look i guess the way that i want
to frame this up is
really i just want to sort of hear your
thoughts on how can
how can we impact the amount of women in
leadership in senior positions
in the recruitment industry so to give
context and i'll share this a couple of
times
and you have a family right you have
children don't you yeah yeah so
so one of the so i want to find out from
you really like
how how you've managed to do both
basically and the reason why i say that
is because
yeah and i just wanted to talk freely
about that really because
one of the things that i continue to
hear and i know it's a complex
multifaceted
issue and challenge right but definitely
one of the common things that i hear is
that whole sort of crossroads that you
must have appeared on or may have it may
have sort of come up for you where
you're like wow
i put all this work into my recruitment
career i'm doing well i want a family
definitely but how am i going to
maintain my career and
like my family life like i don't know
like how that's one thing
one how have you managed that and any
advice for people that
aspiring mothers and people that want a
family to how they can maintain both and
two like how can we move the needle one
more sort of um senior
females in the recruitment industry
um i think um it would definitely have
been a bumpier experience so my kids are
now eleven and nine
um twins and nine and zach's 11. so
i remember um it was a guy actually one
of
a close friend uh i think he was
instrumental in actually writing the
paternity policy it was that
you know archaic there was know in
recruitment
though you know say 12 years ago
organizations didn't even have a
they didn't policy about yeah or child
care yeah yeah
or anything of like that whereas now
it's just sort of like a given that that
would be in place um
i actually remember being absolutely
petrified to tell my boss that i was
pregnant
and and you know trying to pit for a
long time
and you know being probably a little bit
secretive because
you just didn't know what was then was
your desk going to be take away from you
what was going to be the consequence of
that
um going back and and that's what
happened my desk was taken away from me
um and i was also promised a couple of
bonuses
um that then i didn't receive because i
was going off on to to matt lee
i did a lot of i actually opened down
newcastle office
while stagnant um and did a lot of work
very heavily pregnant um and and really
in hindsight probably wouldn't have
busted a gut quite as much if
if i knew that the goal post would have
been moved um
and so you hear of lots of experiences
like that and um
we joined evolution and people were
saying to me you know
having a female on the board was really
welcome could we
could we think about the you know the
return um
journey for women coming back after matt
leave and there was an example of
someone had a rocky time
um i absolutely vowed that um she
wouldn't have a rocky time the second
time around and
we would get our arms around anyone that
was coming back because
for women your confidence is at the
lowest ebb it ever is coming back after
a maternity leave
you've got absolutely absolutely and you
know that needs to be recognized by
leaders
and you need to support these women into
um coming back into an environment that
they can manage
they're daunted by having to leave their
world in the first place
and then how on earth are they going to
have the juggle that
how do you master that how do you master
being the best at work
it is so so so difficult um and so
our jobs as leaders is to make other
people's jobs as easy as we possibly can
not harder
um so as you can tell i've got very very
strong beliefs on this matter
um yeah but it's about absolutely yeah
and
and i would say for anyone returning to
work whether that's because you've cared
for a parent
that's been poor or or for whatever
reason you've been sick yourself or
whatever
all of these things matter um so i think
um in terms of it
it's about sort of you know supporting
supporting those
around us um often on contract
um if uh if someone's going on to matlab
if you don't then get your commission
i think that should be a a whole scale
policy change that you know you've put
those contractors in you should earn
that commission
if that person would be far more likely
to return to a business
if their commission has been kept going
for them
and you know people you know recruitment
companies will say oh they're not likely
to come back well of course they're not
likely to come back if you haven't
treated
them yeah yeah um policy it all comes
down to policy
what about what about um for anyone
listening the
like what would your advice be having
gone through it like a
advice for anyone that is really worried
about telling their
employer i don't know i don't know you
may have had these conversations but
like
what any sort of practical advice there
or anything that
people can think about that might help
in that situation but i can imagine that
being so daunting
and yeah i think
um there's two instances of of women
that have um
gone on matt leave uh that have either
been close to me here at evolution or on
my team
and they were just really really open
and honest and
you know and and one of the girls when
she told me i stood up and gave her a
hug
and she would just wasn't expecting that
she thought that was almost
going to be the opposite of that in fact
um and so i suppose to be the
transparency and
both women actually um continue to do a
little bit of work
on their mat leaves to keep their hand
in
um you obviously get your 10 days to
keep in touch
and but we didn't enforce that if they
didn't want to be
if they did want to it was absolutely
fine um yeah we massive i'd even an hour
coming in and seeing people as a keeping
touch day
um people will do
if you treat people well men or women
they will do their best for you yeah but
i think obviously yeah it's so hard
obviously because there's just so much
nuance and context like to that
situation that
that matters like i i think i guess i
guess the more people that talk about it
hopefully so for example the experiences
that you experience the more people that
hear that and go
oh so that isn't what usually happens or
that isn't
what i should expect the better so then
hopefully that could mean that
more women can be like go into those
conversations more confident and go hey
look the fact that
you're giving me all this limited
support whatever actually that's
actually not that isn't how it's
typically done or that isn't how i'm
hearing other businesses are doing it so
like am i in the right bid like because
yeah because you could be in the wrong
business
or the business doesn't support it
evolution the entire
um i was the first female on that board
so they're all dads and there is a
slight discrepancy in terms of workload
at home
yeah but um but i remember
our ceo sort of touched me on the touch
i was
leaving for interview and said to me um
you know my kids still sleep in my bed
sometimes don't worry about
work you know when people are human
about things
yeah then it actually breaks down those
barriers doesn't it
yeah i love that and obviously anyone
listening the maybe in that situation i
know that
i don't want to put this on you but
they're happy to reach out to you or
do you know because i feel like it's
or you know no one should ever be it's a
horrible thing you should be
really excited to be announcing yeah
exactly
yeah absolutely ashamed or worried or
frightened
um and for me those two things don't
don't you know marry up you should be
proud and excited to explain that you're
going off to have a baby if it's a
wonderful thing in someone's
yeah absolutely right so i've got um
final question for you which is
if if you could change the industry what
what would you improve
um reputation without a doubt i think
you tell people your recruiting they're
going
really are you you say yeah but
yeah and they people have a perception
don't they that they that we're
i don't know just allowed to make a
quick buck or you know that we're not we
do think and
have quality at the the heart of what we
do that we're just throwing cvs at
and making a load money we all know that
actually
you know the skills that's required to
actually
make those placements and revenue is you
know
recruiters have got such a lot of uh
skills in their armory
um and i think um sometimes we don't
help ourselves i think sometimes
recruiters can sort of do themselves
it's
uh um definitely we're competitive with
each other rather than collaborative
in terms of um how i think it's changing
and it's changing slowly
but even things like this wouldn't have
happened 10 years ago we were keeping
all of our ideas to ourselves
so i think that um you know the more
that we can be
open and sort of share the more that the
industry will get a better reputation
i love that bernadette absolute pleasure
bernie should i say i know um i feel
like there's loads more we could talk
about so i feel like we're
gonna have to get a part two for this
but thank you for
being super open honest and joining us
thank you it's a pleasure